roads are cut off homes and businesses
are inundated people in the greater
sydney region are once again underwater
greater sydney faced yet another day of
torrential rain and has already had four
times its normal monthly rainfall more
than 30 000 people across the state have
been told to leave their homes with
australia's largest city facing its
third flood emergency this year they say
no it's a one in one in a hundred year
uh rain one in a hundred uh one in a
thousand or where does it stop you know
what i mean like it's a lot mother
nature leaves
it doesn't spare anyone really and it's
just we're just been really unlucky
so far there has been at least 80
rescues in the worst hit areas with
emergency services helping those
stranded including livestock
with more rain forecast widespread
evacuation orders remain in place for
now
it's obviously been a very difficult
time
for many months
to have this flood event off the back of
others makes it more challenging
the road leading to this community just
north of sydney has been cut off the
river has surged and overflowed
many here are frustrated and say they're
still cleaning up from the last major
flood event in march
the road collapsing hasn't been fixed
since the last floods hasn't been
touched
so now they close
our road access and then the ferry the
only way to get home now is by that
this cargo ship with 21 crew on board is
stranded off the coast of new south
wales it's lost power while authorities
attempt to rescue the crew the ship
risks being swept ashore
these flooded communities face a long
road to recovery with climate scientists
warning weather events like this are
becoming the new norm
for many communities
this is the fourth flood that they have
seen in less than 18 months
and some of those images are truly
heartbreaking seeing people's
homes their lives turned upside down
again
while conditions are set to ease for
some parts of new south wales the
weather bureau says rain and strong
winds will last for the rest of the week
sarah clark al jazeera brisbane
australia